I like super packs and I cannot lie but
the candidates can't did nine when a guy
watching with a big in their taste in
the checkbook in your face you get funds
wanna take big checks but you know
that's not allowed no more than 2,700
how can I get around it I one's an old
baby that's why I'm excited about
citizens united so listen to my story
why super PAC all corporations you wanna
make a donation well bring it bring it
cuz you know there ain't no man man so
make the illusion there ain't no cut
loose that's the dark smart weekend in
this new business apart I'm tired of the
FCC saying regulations are the thing
take the average candidate and ask him
that candidate handing in and donate
donate donate to my back baby got packs
baby packs we're talking about super
PACs which are a little bit more shady
than regular tax but we're calling them
packs in this rap you know we're
rhythmic purposes I like it monogamous
and big anyone can have a pack that's
one for Romney there's even one for
zombies so what do they do pay for ass
so many ads ads Paul Rubio Bush approves
super PACs run asshole they don't lose I
want I'm helping my campaign for a super
PAC to go mini American people these
days seem a bit evil cuz there are some
loopholes getting cash from groups that
don't disclose who their donors are yo
so sometimes nobody knows Hillary
Hillary
put super pressing her artillery she
turned around looked away Priorities USA
baby got PACs
baby got backs
yeah baby when it comes to name and
superPACs make sure you make them sound
real patriotic and wordy working for
working Americans pursuing America's
greatness Americans for America oh and
there's keep the promise one two and
three but what about Obama does he play
into PAC drama sure does without that
money he would have better gone but
Bernie Sanders don't want not not even
from you Yun's
he thinks that they are shady he don't
want none of that some candidates wanna
play old school and save that money
ain't cool turn a protest enough jack
shit but can they win the election so
candidates just remember if you want to
win next November just get yourself some
super PACs but don't forget you may be
tied to some special interests who might
just try to exert their influence over
you now that you're president baby got
back
you